merci la séance est ouverte le
compte-rendu intégral de la séance du
jeudi 5 octobre a été publié sur le site
internet du Sénat il n'y a pas
d'observation le procès verbal est
adopté madame la ministre mes chers
collègues je vous informe que monsieur
le Président du Sénat rendra hommage
demain au début de notre séance de
question d'actualité au gouvernement aux
victimes de l'attaque terroriste du
Hamas sur Israël nous avons par ailleurs
appris avec tristesse le décès de notre
ancienne collègue victoire jasmin qui
siégeait encore il y a peu avec nous
monsieur le Président du Sénat lui
rendra également hommage
demain les conclusions adopté par la
Conférence des Présidents réunis jeudi 5
octobre sont consultables sur le le site
du Sénat en l'absence d'observation je
les considère comme adopté j'informe le
Sénat que le groupe les républicains a
présenté une candidature pour siéger au
sein de la commission des Affaires
social et que le groupe Union centriste
a présenté une candidature pour siéger
au sein de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable ces candidatures
seront ratifiées si la présidence n'a
pas reçu d'opposition dans le délai
d'une heure prévu par notre
règlement j'informe le Sénat que les
candidatures pour siéger au sein de
l'éventuelle commission mixte paritaire
chargée d'élaborer un texte sur le
projet de loi visant à sécuriser et
réguler l'espace numérique ont été
publié ces candidatures seront ratifié
si la présidence n'a pas reçu
d'opposition dans le délai d'une heure
prévu par notre
règlement j'informe le Sénat que les
commissions mixtes paritaires chargé
d'élaborer un texte sur les dispositions
restant en discussion du projet de loi
organique relatif à l'ouverture à la
modernisation et à la responsabilité du
corps judiciaire sur le projet de loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de la Justice
2023-2027 ainsi que sur le projet de loi
relatif à l'industrie verte sont chacune
parvenue à l'adoption d'un texte
commun la parole est à Madame Dominique
Estrosi Sasson pour un rappel au
règlement merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
effectivement je souhaitais faire ce
rappel au règlement pour rappeler aux
membres du gouvernement leur obligation
de répondre aux questions des sénateurs
d'échanger et de débattre avec eux mais
également d'être présent lors de
l'examen d'un texte législatif qui
relève de leur ministère et de leur
compétenence de leur compéten au niveau
du ministère or je regrette madame la
ministre que à ce banc ne soit pas prés
ce jour le nouveau ministre du Logement
qui a accordé une interview il y a 3
jours de cela dans le monde pour donner
quelques lignes sur sa politique du
logement alors que nous avons tout cet
après-midi des débats qui vont porter
justement sur le logement d'abord à
l'initiative du groupe les républicains
un débat sur l'accession à la propriété
qui sera suivi de l'examen d'un texte
législatif la proposition de loi de
notre collègue Sophie prima pour
remettre les maires au cœur du
dispositif d'attribution des logements
sociaux donc le ministre a préféré
accompagner le président de la
République à Hambourg parce que il doit
rencontrer son homologue je pense qu'il
y avait d'autres moments peut-être pour
le faire et donc on regrette que le
nouveau ministre qui avait la l'occasion
de s'adresser à la représentation
parlementaire ici au Sénat dans cette
hémicycle pendant tout l'après-midi et à
parler du logement ne soit pas là
aujourd'hui pour pour le faire c'est ce
que je voulais souligner dans ce rappel
au règlement je pense aussi que
peut-être son déplacement en Allemagne
peut-être lui ouvrira un petit peu la
vue sur les conséquences désastreuses
qu'a eu par exemple la politique massive
de vente de logements sociaux à des
investisseurs institutionnels sur lequel
un certain nombre d'entre nous nous nous
sommes tant émus et opposés depuis 2017
depuis l'arrivée donc du président de la
République Emmanuel Macron aux commande
et donc je que ça lui permettra
peut-être effectivement de prendre
conscience de façon salutaire qu'il faut
changer de cap sur cette politique du
logement pour faire en sorte que nous
soyons enfin dans notre pays en capacité
de répondre à une crise du logement sans
précédent
merci acté donné de ce rappel au
règlement l'ordre du jour appelle le
débat sur l'accession à la propriété
demande du groupe les républicains
la parole est tout d'abord à l'orateur
du groupe qui a demandé ce débat madame
Dominique Estrosi Sasson pour le groupe
les républicain pour 8
[Applaudissements]
minutes monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues notre
groupe les républicains a souhaité
donner un signal très fort dès la
reprise des travaux parlementaires du
Sénat en abordant la crise du logement
qui frappe les Français notre groupe a
choisi de le faire à travers la
problématique de l'accession à la
propriété qui est le rêve et l'idéal de
la plupart de nos concitoyens je
voudrais tout d'abord souligner combien
contrairement à une certaine écologie
punitive et ou collectiviste ce rêve est
au combien légitime chacun aspire à
donner à sa famille un lieu stable et
confortable un foyer où il fait bon
vivre comment projeter de vivre à deux
d'élever des enfants sans se placer dans
cette perspective de leur garantir un
toit au-dessus de leur tête à ce titre
la crise du logement participe
directement à la crise de la natalité
que nous traversons cette sécurité
protectrice que l'on souhaite pour sa
famille nos concitoyens l'espèrent aussi
pour leur vieux jour au moment où les
retraites sont incertaines et dans tous
les cas moins élevé que les reven
d'activité être propriétaire de son
logement c'est normalement un atout pour
maintenir son niveau de vie enfin face
aux difficultés rencontrées par la
jeunesse pour trouver sa place dans
notre société les Français veulent quand
cela leur est possible transmettre un
capital à leurs enfants ou à leurs
petits enfants pour les aider voilà
pourquoi avoir un logement à soi reste
un élément central de toutes les étapes
de la vie et pour tous les Français mais
ces dernières années cet horizon s'est
malheureusement éloigné le rêve est
devenu toujours plus difficile à
atteindre ce qui a des conséquences sur
toute la chaîne du logement le
pourcentage des ménages prioritaire et
propriétaire était en 2022 de
57,7 %. il stagne depuis 2010 alors
qu'il était croissant depuis les années
1970 les raison en sont les effets
durables de la crise économique de 2008
et la hausse continue des pris
immobiliers qui a été en partie soutenue
et compensé par une politique de taux
d'intérêt bas mais depuis le
déclenchement de la guerre en Ukraine
ces difficultés latente ont été
démultipliées par une inflation qui
ronge le pouvoir d'achat et la hausse
brutale des taux d'intérêt à peine
atténué par le début de baisse des prix
à cela s'ajoute les tensions
structurelles du marché dans les grandes
villes historiques où il est de plus en
plus difficile de construire ou de
densifier l'existant alors même que
l'affirmation de l'objectif de zéro
artificialisation nette rend impossible
la solution traditionnelle d'extension
des métropoles et crée des rentes de
situations cette problématique ne
pourrait être que macro-économique mais
elle est en réalité sociale et
profondément politique
le blocage de l'accès à la propriété
équivaut au blocage de l'ascenseur
social et donne à nos compatriotes un
sentiment de précarisation et de
déclassement par rapport aux générations
qui les ont précédé en effet il rend
impossible le parcours accompli par ses
parents ou par ses grands-parents jeunes
on est traditionnellement locataire dans
le parc social ou dans le parc privé
d'un petit logement plutôt suroccupé du
fait de l'arrivée des enfants on réussit
progressivement à s'agrandir et à
devenir propriétaire au fur et à mesure
de sa vie professionnelle puis avec le
départ des enfants on dispose en général
d'un logement plus grand dont on est
propriétaire et dans lequel on pourra
recevoir sa famille de fait 79 % des
propriétaires occupants disposent d'une
maison ils ont en moyenne 60 ans et la
maison fait 100 m² et compte 4 pièces de
plus enfin le blocage de l'accession a
des effets en chaînes sur ensemble du
parcours résidentiel des ménages qui se
trouvent bloqués en effet les ménages
qui ne peuvent plus devenir
propriétaires ne quittent plus leur
logement locatif que ce soit dans le
parc privé comme dans le parc social
dans les zones tendues la mobilité
résidentielle dans le parc social a
fortement baissé diminuant d'autant le
nombre de logements attribuables la
construction de nouveaux logements
sociaux ne peut pas répondre à elle
seule à la demande l'accroissement sans
limite du parc social ne peut pas être
le seul horizon alors que la durée de
résidence dans le parc social est déjà
deux fois plus longue que dans le parc
locatif privé et que 17,6 % des ménages
y sont déjà logés rêve largement partagé
symbole d'ascenseur social l'accession à
la propriété est aujourd'hui menacée et
elle doit être relancée plusieurs
voudraient masquer les difficultés
d'accès à la propriété et le manque de
volonté de les surmonter certains
expliquent que les jeunes générations
seraient maintenant tourné vers
l'économie du partage et de l'usage
plutôt que de la propriété et qu'ell ne
souhaiteraiit plus devenir propriétaire
cela me laisse dubitative en France la
décohabitation des jeunes était jusqu'à
jusqu'à récemment la plus précoce en
Europe marquant une Scine volonté
d'indépendance sa régression récente
dénote en réalité de graves problèmes
économiques et d'entré dans la vie
active certains voudraient aussi
délégitimer toute politique d'accession
à la propriété comme étant directement
synonyme d'étalement urbains et
d'artificialisation des sols ces idées
ont conduit au résultat plus que
décevant du Conseil national de la
refondation sur le logement et qui au
lieu d'aboutir à une relance du secteur
ont servi à justifier de nouvelles
coupes budgétair dans les aides au
logement sans autre finalité que de
réduire le déficit personne n'en est
dupe parmi celle-ci ce qui est
publiquement appelé le rentrage du PTZ
du pré àau zéro porte un coût direct aux
capacités d'accession à la propriété de
très nombreux ménages il y a 6 ans
maintenant en 2017 il en avait été de
même avec laap accession alors qu'était
dans le même temps promu la vente de
logements sociaux à leurs occupants ici
nous n'avons eu de cess sur les rangs de
la majorité sénatoriale de remettre la p
l'accession qui n'a été malheureusement
à chaque fois que enlevé par l'Assemblée
nationale quel dommage pour tous ces
ménages modestes qui ne peuvent plus
bénéficier de ce coût de pouce notre
groupe croit au contraire que
l'accession à la propriété est un
objectif qui mérite d'être de nouveau
promu par les pouvoirs publics je
voudrais simplement esquisser quelques
pistes qui seront approfondis au cours
du débat nous sommes dans une période de
taux d'intérêt élevé qui relance des
outils comme le PTZ pour l'achat comme
pour la les travaux de rénovation
énergétique dans de telles circonstances
il serait aussi pertinent de proposer à
nouveau la déductibilité au moins
partielle des intérêts d'emprunt pour la
première acquisition nous constatons
également une forte différence entre les
générations qui ont pu devenir
propriétaires et les plus jeunes ne
serait-il pas pertinent d'encourager à
nouveau la transmission précoce du
patrimoine vers les enfants ou vers les
petits-enfants en vue de l'acquisition
de la résidence principale du ménage
voilà mes chers collègues madame la
ministre monsieur le Président quelques
pistes que nous allons développer dans
le cadre du débat pour relever le défi
de l'accession à la propriété
aujourd'hui et surtout ne pas répondre
au sentiment de frustration et de
déclassement des Français ne pas relever
la crise du logement c'est ne pas
répondre à un besoin essentiel de nos
compatriotes c'est surtout prendre le
risque d'un détricotage des solidarités
concrètes que traduisent les politiques
de l'habitat et au final de notre Pact
social je vous
remercie
merci la parole est à Madame Dominique
fort ministre délégué chargé des
collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité pour 8
minutes merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
alors sur ce débat sur l'accession à la
propriété je souhaite évidemment excuser
mon mon collègue Patrice vergrit qui
effectivement a répondu positivement à
l'invitation du président de la
République de se rendre en Allemagne et
j'espère être à la hauteur de des débats
en tout cas je ferai de mon mieux le
gouvernement est pleinement conscient de
la crise immobilière des ventes dans
l'ancien dans le UF qui bloque le
parcours résidentiel de beaucoup de
ménages en France en effet l'accession à
la propriété est devenue bien plus
difficile pour de nombreux ménages faute
d'un crédit abordable avec des taux
d'intérêt multipliés par 3 voire 4 alors
que les prix qui ont également été
impactés par l'inflation consécutive au
conflit ukrainien ne diminue pas
vraiment comme vous l'avez
indiqué conséquence de cette situation
l'accès à un logement locatif est
également plus compliqué dans de
nombreuses villes les locataires en
place pénant à quitter leur logement
pour poursuivre leur parcours
résidentiel ce qui bloque les nouveaux
entrants sur le marché parti
particulièrement les étudiants les
jeunes actifs mais aussi les ménages en
mobilité ou en séparation face à cette
situation le gouvernement cherche à
combiner plusieurs mesures sans croire
dans la mesure miracle qui permettrait
de résoudre toute la crise d'un coup il
s'agit d'intervenir sur tous les
segments de l'offre dont l'accession à
la propriété je citerai quatre axes
d'action sur ce sujet d'abord le
gouvernement agit pour faciliter l'accès
au cré des Françaises et des Français
faut rappeler en premier le que la
France reste l'un des pays de l'Union
européenne où la production de crédit à
l'habitat est la plus dynamique sur les
derniers mois plus de 70000 ménages ont
trouvé un crédit chaque mois soit une
production qui se maintient à près de 11
milliards mensuels certes c'est une
division par presque deux par rapport
aux années fastes entre 2019 et 2022
mais c'est un niveau qui reste élevé par
rapport à nos voisins européens et qui
reste usuel par rapport aux périodes de
taux plus élevé c'est aussi une chute de
la production liée à une baisse de la
demande les banques reçoivent 25 à 40 %
de dossierers en moins environ car les
acheteurs éventuels attendent une baisse
des prix à laquel les vendeurs ne sont
pas encore prêts toutefois le
gouvernement continue de travailler avec
les banques pour dynamiser la production
de crédit à l'habitat dans un contexte
où la hausse des taux pourrait se
poursuivre mais à un rythme moins
important des mesures ont déjà été
prises sous l'impulsion de Bruno l maire
le taux d'usure a été mensualisé par la
Banque de France pour s'adapter plus
rapidement à la forte remontée des taux
certaines marges opérationnelles ont été
mises en place par le Haut Comité pour
la stabilité financière pour permettre
aux banques de déroger aux règles en
vigueur concernant la durée maximale
d'endettement de 25 ans ou le taux
maximal d'endettement 35 % des
revenus 20 % des dossiers peuvent
aujourd'hui déroger à ces règles et le
gouvernement cherchera avec les banques
à garantir l'utilisation maximale de ces
marges tout en maintenant les principes
du cadre actuel qui permet d'éviter
évidemment le surendettement des ménages
par ailleurs le gouvernement est tout à
fait disposé à étudier avec le secteur
bancaire tous les dispositifs innovants
de financement de l'accession à la
propriété susceptible de générer une
baisse de la charge financière pour les
accédentss crédit avec remboursement
Infiné modèle basé sur des formes de
démembrement accession progressive à la
propriété ensuite le gouvernement agit
pour solvabiliser les Françaises et les
Français par le prêt à taux zéro dans
les zones où les prix du logement neuf
sont les plus élevés le prêt à taux zéro
sera maintenu et
élargi le gouvernement soutient
également l'accession sociale à la
propriété qui permet de faire dimin uer
le prix des logements en accession à la
propriété le PTS le PTZ sera ainsi
maintenu pour toute accession sociale
neuve à la propriété dans tout le pays
par ailleurs la quotité du PTZ pour la
vente HLM sera doublée par un amendement
du PLF 2024 concrètement les ménages de
la classe moyenne ou des classes
populaires qui souhaiteraient acquérir
leur logement social bénéficieront d'un
montant d'emprunt gratuit deux fois plus
élevé à partir de
2024 enfin le gouvernement souhaite
dynamiser le BRS le bail réel solidaire
ce dispositif a été inventé en 2018 par
la loi hlan il a fait ses preuves depuis
1000 logements sont sortis de terre
11500 sont en projet 150 offices
fonciers ont été créés notamment par les
collectivités et de plus en plus de
communes fixe une BAR une part de BRS
dans leur programme
ne9u le BRS c'est aussi comptabilisé
dans le cadre de la loi SRU ce qui
encourage les élus locaux à porter le
produit ce BRS dans les communes
déficitaire en complément de
l'indispensable production de logements
locatifs sociaux pour le dynamiser le
gouvernement va étendre les ménages
éligies éligibles au BRS par arrêté dans
les prochaines semaines et ceci par
arrêté il va aussi initier un plan
global sur le développement du produit
pour aller encore plus loin ce plan
prévoira une misation des acteurs une
simplification de la réglementation
applicable et une meilleure diffusion de
l'information auprès des acteurs de
terrain pour qu'il s'approprie au mieux
ce dispositif enfin le gouvernement agit
pour donner des outils aux collectivités
locales pour réguler leur parc de
logement et favoriser les résidences
principales quand les élus souhaitent en
faire une priorité c'est le sens des
discussions qui se tiendront dans les
prochains jours à l'Assemblée sur la
fiscalité locative il y a de nombreuses
propositions sur la table et nous
espérons que le débat parlementaire
permettra de dégager un consensus
intelligent prenant en compte les
spécificités des territoires tout en
favorisant la location longue
durée c'est aussi le sens du travail en
cours pour de nouveaux outils de
régulation pour les communes aujourd'hui
dans les communes qui le souhaitent il
est déjà possible de mettre en place
l'autorisation de changement d'usage
pour contrôler le nombre de résidences
secondaires qui peuvent accueillir de la
location tour que de courte durée est
aussi possible de mettre en place une
compensation et de demander en
contrepartie que des locaux existants
qui ne sont pas des logements soit
transformé en long en logement de longue
durée mais nous souhaitons aller plus
loin avec vous avec tous les
parlementaires dans les prochaines
semaines pour concrétiser rapidement les
annonces que nous avons faites devant le
groupe de travail lutte contre
l'attrition du logement permanent en
zone touristique et ça c'était le 18
juillet dernier mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs ces quelques axes témoin
de la la variété des réponses qui sont
apportées par notre gouvernement et
particulièrement par mon collègue
Patrice vergrit pour faciliter l'accès à
la propriété des Françaises et des
Français plus largement l'accès à une
résidence principale bien sûr et bien
entendu ces mesures sont complémentaires
d'autres travaux en cours pour produire
davantage de logements sociaux de
logements intermédiaires abordables
soutenir la production de logement au
sens large ou encore accompagner l'offre
de logement dans les territoires en
industrialisation ou dans les
territoires en
redynamisation je vous
remercie merci madame la ministre dans
la suite du débat chaque orateur dispose
de 2 minutes maximum y compris
l'éventuelle réplique le gouvernement
dispose pour répondre d'une durée
équivalente le gouvernement aura la
faculté s'il le juge nécessaire de
répondre à une réplique pendant une
minute l'auteur de la question disposera
alors à son tour du droit de réponse
pendant une minutes la parole est au
président Alain Marc merci monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre pour un
grand nombre de nos concitoyens l'accès
à la propriété synonyme d'indépendance
et de sécurité matérielle accéder à la
propriété permet non seulement de
constituer un investissement rentable
notamment en prévision de la de la
retraite mais également de disposer d'un
patrimoine réputé sûr et transmissible
aux héritiers or les Français ont de
plus en plus de mal à acquérir un bien
immobilier je pense notamment à tous ces
jeunes actifs qui ne sont plus en mesure
d'accéder à la propriété dans les
territoires qui les ont vu naître
l'augmentation du coût des matériaux la
hausse du prix des terrain et la
remontée des taux d'intérêt des crédits
qu' placent les Français modestes et les
classes moyennes dans l'incapacité
d'emprunter freineent considérablement
l'accession à la propriété le mois
dernier pour tenter de contenir
l'inflation la Banque centrale
européenne a de nouveau relevé ses taux
directeur portant le taux de dépôt à 4 %
soit un niveau jamais atteint depuis le
lancement de la monnaie unique en 1999
le prix du crédit va donc continuer à
augmenter et restreindre ainsi le nombre
de candidats à l'obtention d'un prêt
immobilier parallèlement les mises en
chantier dans le bâtiment neuf
s'écroulent et le zéro artificialisation
nette va constituer un obstacle
supplémentaire aux nouvelles
constructions et participer à la hausse
du prix de l'immobilier madame la
ministre alors qu'elle doit être une
opportunité offerte au plus grand nombre
l'accession à la propriété connaît
actuellement une crise sans précédent
aussi pouvez-vous nous indiquer les
mesures de soutien que le gouvernement
envisage de mettre en œuvre afin de
relancer la construction et favoriser
l'accès de tous nos concitoyens à la
propriété merci Madame la
Ministre merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Député
Marc nous partageons
totalement pardon monsieur le sénateur
Marc comme indiqué lors de la discussion
générale nous partageons le diagnostic
et nous sommes
solidaires de l'absolue nécessité de
faire face à cette crise de la
production de
logement j'ai eu l'occasion de vous
présenter un certain nombre de mesures
dans ma déclaration générale qui
répondent en grande partie aux
problématiques que vous posez encore une
fois et que je partage simplement je
souhaite évoquer à l'occasion de cette
question euh quelques mesures
complémentaires engagées que je n'ai pas
été amené à développer dans ma
déclaration générale sur le logement
locatif social nous avons signé la
semaine dernière un accord avec le
mouvement HLM qui prévoit la mise en
place de 8 milliards de prê bonifiés
pendant 3 ans pour soutenir la
production de logements locatifs très
sociaux sur le secteur locatif en
entérinant la fin du dispositif Pinel
que l'on considère coûteux et peu
efficace nous mettons en place des
dispositions pour accroître la
production de logement intermédiaire
pour cela nous avons élargi le périmètre
des communes éligibles à ce dispositif
donc
oui chère Madame donc vous l'avez
compris j'ai cité un certain nombre
d'actions sur votre question pendant ma
déclaration générale et je m'efforcerai
de ne pas les répéter parce que je pense
que vous avez tous bien écouté et que
vous allez répondre à ces propositions
et en tout cas voilà les compléments que
je voulais vous apporter par rapport à
ma déclaration générale merci à vous
merci Monsieur Marc il vous reste 26
secondes oui il ne s'agit pas tant de
logement locatif
mais nous souhaitons dans nos milieux
ruraux que les gens puissent accéder à
la propriété il me semble qu'au niveau
social c'est la meilleure des choses et
toutes les actions qui pourront être
engagé en faveur de cette accession à la
propriété me semble de bon
loi merci la parole est à Madame Amel
gaker pour 2 minutes monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre chers
collègues je j'ai attentivement écouté
madame la ministre vos propos
liminires à la question de la crise du
logement c'est par un arsenal de mesures
techniques que le gouvernement que vous
nous répondez systématiquement et
pourtant cela a été dit le sujet du
logement est éminemment social
économique et politique aujourd'hui
c'est de l'accession à la propriété dont
il s'agit de la possibilité pour les
Français de réaliser un de leurs rêves
devenir propriétaire mais force est de
constater que justement devenir
propriétaire un des principaux mote de
la progression sociale est en panne cela
a été dit je le rappelle 57 % des
ménages sont propriétaires de leur
résidence principale cette proportion de
la population est figée depuis 2010
alors qu'elle n'avait cessé de croître
depuis les années 80 le gouvernement
vous déclarz être favorable au
développement de l'accession à la
propriété or nous assistons au
déploiement d'une politique qui provoque
tout l'inverse un accès au préimmobilier
de plus en plus complexe extinction de
feu de dispositifs pardon visant à
faciliter la primo accession l'explosion
du prix de la pierre un foncier de plus
en plus rare face à ce phénomène nous
nous interrogeons sur vos véritables
intentions madame la ministre ma
question porte sur la vision du
gouvernement de l'accession à la
propriété dans notre pays êtes-vous
réellement favorable à une France de
propriétaire si oui comment allez-vous
soutenir l'accession à la propriété
particul ement pour les ménages les plus
modestes je vous remercie merci Madame
la
Ministre
oui merci monsieur le Président et
madame la sénatrice carer g donc je
elle a dit que c'était pas grave madame
la sénatrice merci de votre
bienveillance donc en fait je partage
votre sentiment sur le fait que on est
sur un sujet social et économique et
politique absolument complexe et pour ce
qui est de votre sujet qui est l'objet
de nos travaux cet après-midi on est sur
le champ de l'accession à la propriété
je l'ai bien compris mais j'ai tenté
dans ma déclaration générale de vous
expliquer à quel point tous les sujets
étaient imbriqués ensuite quand vous
dites j'ai des doutes et je le respecte
sur quelle est votre politique à vous le
gouvernement les points que vous évoquez
j'ai pas eu le temps de tous les noter
mais ils sont tous absolument
conjoncturels et on les subit
l'augmentation
des taux d'intérêt liés à l'inflation le
foncier qui est rare oui on a mis en
place une loi qui vise mais je pense
qu'elle ne fait plus débat à
effectivement être beaucoup plus sobre
sur le plan du foncier donc vous dire
que le dispositif du PTZ que je vous ai
évoqué et qui a quand même largement
élargi ses bases sur lesquelles il va
pouvoir s'appliquer a bien vocation à
aider les classe moyenne à acquérir un
bien neuf voilà dans les zones tendues
son élargissement et l'amélioration ses
caractéristiques en 2024 devrait mieux
solvabiliser les Primot accédentss les
prix dans l'ancien ou dans le neuf
dépassent parfois 6000 € du mètre carré
ce qui est le cas en région parisienne
sur une partie de la région PACA et sur
certaines zones frontalières même avec
un PTZ la l'accession à la propriété
pour les classes moyennes dans le neu
reste difficile je vous l'ai dit on
partage votre diagnostic certaines
collectivités imposent aux promoteurs de
consacrer une partie de leur programme à
des logements en accession à prix
métrisé ou abordable vous n'êtes pas
sans savoir que maintenant le PSLA fait
partie euh de ces logements qui
permettent de rentrer dans la loi SRU on
est dans l'accession sociale certes mais
on est dans l'accession à la propriété
euh et donc l'idée est de vous dire que
l'on a agi et que l'on agit et on va
encore agir ensemble pour faire en sorte
que l'accession à la propriété soit
facilitée malgré les contraintes que
vous avez cité et que nous
subissons merci Mad la ministre madame
gquer reste 19
secondes merci vous voyez madame la
ministre vous tombez toujours dans le
même travers je vous pose la question de
connaître vos orientations politique
vous me répondez
technique que voulez-vous quelle France
de propriétaire voulez-vous 70 % de
propriétaires 80 % de propriétaires dans
10 ans et bien nous n'avons toujours pas
de réponse à la question nous ne sommes
toujours pas rassurés je vous
remercie merci la parole est à Monsieur
Yannick
pour le
groupe merci monsieur le Président
Madame min chers collègues c'est peut
dire que le logement connaît une crise
extrêmement grave historique et c'est
aussi madame la ministre le résultat du
fiasco de votre gouvernement depuis 6
ans on a cette année 30 % de
construction de logement neuf en moins
on a dans le logement social on va
probablement pas dépasser 90000 nouveaux
logements sociaux alors qu'il y a 6 ans
on était encore à 125000 sur ce dossier
vous faites de l'argent 10 milliards sur
Action Logement et vous avez des
discours mais malheureusement même le
ministre ne considère pas que c'est un
débat essentiel alors vous en appelez à
la responsabilité des élus locaux il y a
des élus locaux qui font le boulot et
qui font bien le boulot notamment sur
une initiative que vous avez mentionn le
le bail réel
solidaire la ville de Lyon par exemple
le planifie 1000 BRS par an et bien dans
ce cas-là madame qu'est-ce que vous
envisagez pour que la banque des
territoires qui doit être l'outil en
faveur de ce type d'instrument massifie
mobilise beaucoup plus beaucoup plus de
financement pour que les offices
fonciers puissent investir et de faire
de cet accession à la
semiprpriété Une une réussite en France
merci merci Madame la minist
ministre monsieur le Président je vous
remercie monsieur le sénateur jade là
pour le coup vous faites une prise de
parole politique à laquelle je ne vais
pas répondre de façon politique mais de
la façon la plus précise possible encore
une fois vous êtes en train de poser un
diagnostic et et vous accuser le
gouvernement moi j'ai envie de de vous
dire que les propositions que vous
faites en conclusion de votre prise de
parole ben elles sont à l'œuvre vous
nous parlez du BRS qui a voté le BRS
c'est notre gouvernement et c'est depuis
2017 que nous avons
porté
ce ce
BRS ce BRS qui nous est si cher et dont
vous ventez les mérites moi je fais
partie de ceux qui dans les zones tendu
dans les zones dans lesquelles les
mètres carrés est très élevé le BRS est
très utile ensuite vous demandez à ce
que la banque des territoires intervient
de façon beaucoup plus massivement mais
elle est actionnaire aujourd'hui de tous
les offices fonciers de tous et donc
aujourd'hui elle joue pleinement son
rôle là où on peut peut-être diverger
mais c'est l'ancienne élu local qui va
vous parler c'est que vous attendez
peut-être euh de l'État qu'il dicte au
collectivité locale comment ils doivent
embarquer tel ou tel dispositif et là on
est dans la libre administration de nos
collectivités et effectivement les
collectivités sont teinté de C de là des
politiques publiques qu'elles portent et
donc nous on est là pour mettre les
outils pour poser le même diagnostic que
vous pour trouver des outils pour
accélérer l'accession sociale comme
l'accession classique à la propriété qui
fait partie de notre socle et sur lequel
nous travaillons
assisument merci Monsieur jade il vous
reste 40 secondes pour la réplique bon
je remarque madame la ministre que vous
prétendez répondre techniquement j'ai
pas entendu un seul chiffre sur comment
la banque des territoires va être
abondée pour qu'on atteignne un chiffre
de 40000 BRS par an ce qui serait la
contribution de cette de ce dispositif à
la construction de nouveau logement mais
aujourd'hui madame la ministre c'est
aussi la journée internationale de lutte
contre le sansabrisme et vous avez toute
une série de villes qui aujourd'hui ont
porté recours contre l'État parce que
l'État ne ne ne fait pas ses obligations
en matière d'accueil d'urgence
330000 sans abri dans notre pays cela
ils sont très loin de l'accession à la
propriété mais ils dépendent de la
solidarité nationale ils dépendent de
l'effort du gouvernement et vous avez
Paris Grenoble Lyon Bordeaux Rennes qui
aujourd'hui demande à ce que le le
gouvernement fasse son travail merci
merci la parole est à Madame Marianne
Margaté ah madame la ministre vous
souhaitez
répondre juste dire un mot sur le fait
que les offic fonciers dont je vous
parle ils sont portés par les
collectivités à leur initiative il n'y a
pas aujourd'hui de limitation de
participation d' ca des dépôts quand
vous dit qu'il nous faudrait mettre de
l'argent massivement que la banque des
territoires la caiss des dépôts mè de
l'argent massivement c'est le cas il y a
pas de limite à ce niveau-là nous
sommes
totalement convaincu de l'efficacité de
la banque des territoires sur le sujet
du logement évidemment mais au travers
d'outils réglementaires existants qui
nous paraissent pertinents à condition
que les collectivités s'en saisissent
merci Monsieur Jad vous souhaitez
répondre pour une minute journée
internationale du sansabrisme j'aurais
aimé avoir une réponse ça concerne
330000 de nos concitoyens merci la
parole est à Madame Marian Marg pour le
groupe r ce kanaki pour 2
minutes monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre chers collègues il y a
effectivement un grave problème de
logement en France et je me réjouis que
ce sujet ouvre la session parlementaire
et pour cause 2,4 millions de personnes
sont en attente d'un logement social 4
millions souffrent du mallogement 330000
sont sans domicile fixe et ça vient
d'être appelé en théorie faciliter
l'accès à la propriété c'est permettre à
celles et ceux qui le peuvent de libérer
des logements en location et à des
nouveaux locataires de libérer parfois
des places d'hébergement c'est ainsi
qui'est pensé le parcours résidentiel en
théorie seulement car quand bien même il
n'y aurait pas des taux d'intérêt
exubérant multiplié par 3 et demi en un
an et demi quand bien même il n aurait
assez de construction il en faut près de
200000 par an dans le social et autant
dans le privé l'accès à la propriété
resterait pour beaucoup un rêve lointain
les causes des difficultés d'accès à la
propriété sont multiples mais disons-le
les bas salaires d'abord et bien sûr nos
concitoyens sont de plus en plus
nombreux à ne plus pouvoir terminer le
mois comment voulez-vous qu'ils
épargnent qu'ils investissent le prix du
foncier dans les métropoles notamment
mais pas seulement je suis sénatrice de
sanemarne et je le mesure
particulièrement le prix du foncier est
aussi le premier facteur responsable du
coût exorbitant des logements il y a des
solutions qui existent nous les avons
cité comme le bail réel et solidaire
pour réduire le coût du foncier dans les
acquisitions mais il y a aussi un enjeu
je de lutte contre la
spéculation sinon les égalités se
creusent et l'héritage d'un patrimoine
est aujourd'hui le meilleur moyen de
devenir propriétaire avec en plus des
multipropriétaires qui s'accaparent les
logements disponibles pour en faire une
rente renforçant ainsi la dynamique
inégalitaire à l'œuvre ma question est
donc simple madame la ministre êtes-vous
prête à prendre en main ce sujet en
ajustant contre la spéculation
immobilière et ainsi permettre plus
largement l'accès à la propriété qui
contribue au respect du droit au
logement je vous remercie madame la
ministre euh madame la sénatrice Margaté
euh je partage aussi tout ce que vous
avez dit sur le parcours résidentiel
absolument nécessaire et puis la pénurie
de logement la crise du logement mais je
vais pas redévelopper tout ça je veux
simplement vous dire toutes les actions
que nous conduisons mais que vous
connaissez au travers d'outils que vous
connaissez comme les établissements
publics fonciers locaux comme les
établissements public foncier d'État qui
sont là pour que nous puissions soit
aider les collectivités soit nous l'état
maîtriser le foncier et lutter contre
cette inflation du fruit du foncier que
vous avez cité donc à ce jour le constat
nous le partageons les solutions c'est
sont les outils que l'on a cité déjà
plusieurs fois j'y rajoute
l'établissement publics fonciers local
et les établissements publics fonciers
d'État qui nous permettent de maîtriser
le foncier et d'accompagner nos Primot
accédants dans l'accession sociale ou la
accession tout court que nous voulons
absolument permettre aux Français
d'accéder merci la parole est à Madame
Annique Girardin pour 2
minutes faut appuyer sur le faut
appuyer madame madame la ministre la
pénurie de logement est la bome sociale
des années à venir et les blocages sont
connu de tous et partagé par tous ici
sur ces banc pas assez de logements
sociaux àoué pas assez de logement
locatif privé àoué une accession à la
propriété gravement en panne avec un
prix de l'immobilier qui a flambé avec
des taux d'intérêt qui monent pourtant
l'habitat comme le enfin pardon pourtant
l'habitat oui comme le travail participe
on en est tous d'accord ici de la
dignité et de l'émancipation des
individus c'est pour cela que nous nous
sénateurs du groupe RDSE croyant que le
plein logement est une priorité comme le
plein emploi et avec le droit au
logement nous sommes attachés
précisément au droit à la propriété car
n'est-ce pas par l'alliance des
travailleurs et des petits propriétaires
urbains ruraux et ultramarins qu' a pu
émerger une république sociale au cours
des deux derniersr des deux derniers
siècles comment répondre alors à la
demande d'accession à la propriété socle
de notre société française face à la
crise actuelle de pouvoir d'achat alors
oui des solutions existent pra social
location accession vous en avez parlé
créé en 2004 étendu à l'ancien en 2020
le bail réel solidaire créé en 2016 et
bien entendu dans les outres-mèes l'aide
à l'AC l'accession sociale à la
propriété et la sortie de l'insalubrité
créé en 2019 pourtant force de constater
que ça ne s'améliore pas et que pour la
plupart de nos concitoyens sur ce sujet
il est quand même très compliqué
aujourd'hui d'avoir accès à la propriété
certes le gouvernement vient juste de
décider le relèvement des plafonds des
revenus des ménages éligibles et puis le
maintien du prêt à taux zéro pour ce
type d'acquisition mais si on prend les
chiffres 14000 locations accession dans
le neu loin d'être suffisant et et la
question des 12000 ventes dans le parc
existant euh qui se font d'ailleurs avec
des garanties
euh suffisantes ou pas pour la qualité
de ses logements parce que sur le moyen
et sur le long terme il y a de véritable
question alors ma question elle est si
le bail réel solidaire présente ces
garanties grâce aux offices fanciers
solidaires qui les supporte hein
d'ailleurs comment comptez-vous
faciliter son déploiement massif urgent
sur l'ensemble de notre pays tant dans
les territoire ultrarin que dans
l'Hexagone merci Madame la
Ministre merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice
Girardin donc euh vous soutenez un droit
au logement un droit à la propriété vous
dites que des solutions existent elles
sont pour l'instant effectivement pas
suffisamment efficace puisque on parle
effectivement depuis une petite heure
euh de cette crise du logement donc
simplement je voudrais compléter tous
les propos que j'ai déjà tenus sur
effectivement le mouvement HLM qui
réalise et vous l'avez dit 14000
logements en accession sociale chaque
année et on continue à soutenir ces
dispositifs ouverts au pts partout en
France au PTZ pardon partout en France
au sein de cette offre le bail réel
solidaire conna est un réel engouement
vous dites pas suffisamment vous avez
raison mais effectivement le dispositif
est là et il est satisfaisant mais il
faut lui laisser le temps et laisser le
temps au collectivité locale de se
l'approprier il connaît un réel
engouement des opérateurs avec plus de
100 organismes fonciers solidairire
agréé existe aujourd'hui certaines
collectivités imposent d'ailleurs aux
promoteurs dorénavant de réaliser dans
leur projet de quotas de logement d'en
faire certains en BRS donc nous allons
soutenir le développement de ce produit
abordable non spéculative en augmentant
les plafonds de ressources vous l'avez
dit du dispositif et en lançant un
véritable plan de déploiement du BRS je
vous REM merci la parole est à Monsieur
Bernard buy pour le groupe
RDPI pour 2
minutes merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
si les crises et les défis s'accumulent
dans la période que nous vivons force de
constater que le secteur du logement n'y
échappe pas le marché de l'accession à
la propriété est en déclin pour le neuf
comme pour l'existant pourtant accéder à
la propriété doit demeurer une liberté
une possibilité pour les Français face à
ce constat alarmant profitons de ce
débat pour parler des solutions et en ce
qui me concerne j'envoie deux d'une part
le prêt à taux zéro d'autre part le bail
réel solidaire deux outils qui seront
amenés à être modifié selon les récentes
annonces du ministre chargé du logement
dans la presse d'abord sur le prê à tau
zéro rappelons-le prédestiné à l'achat
d'un logement neuf ou d'un logement à
réhabilité sans frais de dossier et dont
les intérêts sont à la charge de l'État
dans quelle mesure les conditions
d'accès à ce prêt seront-elles modifiées
et dans quelle
commune ensuite reconnaissons
l'importance du bail réel solidaire un
dispositif créé en 2015 qui permet à des
ménages modestes de devenir propriétaire
d'un logement neuf situé en zone tendue
et ce à a un prix réduit obtenu en
dissociant le bâti du terrain mais il
faut aller encore plus loin alors madame
la ministre comment accompagner les
communes sur le développement de ce bail
réel solidaire enfin Madame la Ministre
d'autres solutions pourrai-elles être
envisager afin de faciliter
l'accessibilité à la propriété des
français alors que la crise du logement
est bel et bien
amorcée merci Madame la
Ministre merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Sénateur
buis donc vous évoquez deux sujets dans
on a largement parlé le préato zéro le
le bail réel solidaire quelques chiffres
qui peut-être répondront aux attentes du
sénateur jado qui malheureusement nous a
quitté
donc sur ce qui est du PTZ notre
objectif est d'atteindre 40000 PTZ en
2024 40000 avec une répartition sur
l'ensemble des tranches de revenus et la
création d'une tranche supplémentaire de
revenus l'élargissement de l'accès au
PTZ et la conséquence de l'arrêté flash
relative au zonage qui a permis de
classer 154 communes en zone tendue et
de faire passer 55 communes de la zone
B1 à la zone A les ménages de ces
communes qui regroupent près de 5
millions d'habitants bénéficieront donc
d'un accès au PTZ amélioré pour des
opérations neuves en 2024 ensuite sur le
second sujet vous euh demandez à quel
point nous pouvons encore plus
accompagner les collectivités local pour
faire ce choix du BRS donc j'ai indiqué
que beaucoup de collectivités commençai
à mettre des quotas de BRS dans leur
programme de logement neuf j'ai indiqué
qu'il existait aujourd'hui près de 150
organismes de fonciers solidaires nos
fameux OFS et les services déconcentrés
de l'État sont déjà au travail pour
promouvoir ces outils et ces OFS et les
associations assation régionale de
bailleurs sociaux se traînent sont aussi
à la disposition des élus pour leur
expliquer comment monter une opération
si elle leur apparaît encore innovante
que de monter une opération BRS donc je
l'ai déjà dit mais je vous le redis
malgré la présence des outils
aujourd'hui bien que beaucoup de
collectivités s'en saisissent le
gouvernement envisage de lancer un
véritable plan pour le développement du
BRS dans les prochains mois tout en
laissant le libre arbitre à nos
collectivités locales merci Monsieur
buis il vous reste 28 secondes c'est bon
alors la parole est à Madame Vivian
Artigalas pour le groupe
SRE merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre l'accession à la propriété
particulièrement complexe dans les zones
touristiques ou dans les zones où le
prix du foncier a explosé ces dernières
années les jeunes ménagent mais pas
seulement non'ont plus les moyens de se
loger dans leur région d'origine ou près
de leur lieu de travail je souhaiterais
vous interroger moi aussi sur sur le
bail réel solidaire créé en 2015 et non
pas en 2018 comme vous l'avez dit ce
dispositif d'accession à la propriété
qui permet au ménages modeste de devenir
propriétaire d'un logement neuf situé en
zone tendue à un prix abordable à
plusieurs avantages en dissociant le
foncier du bâti l'acquerreur n'acquiert
que le logement et loue son terrain à un
organisme de foncier solidaire ce qui
représente pour lui entre 20 et 40 %
d'économie selon les secteurs
géographiques mais il a un autre
avantage le bien acheté ne peut être
utilisé qu'en résidence principale et ne
peut pas changer de destination ce qui
invite la stagnation des biens en
résidence secondaire alors que l'offre
de logement est sousenstion mais il y a
un point négatif le financement de ce
dispositif ne concerne que les zones
tendu certes le décret du 26 août
dernier en révisant leur zonage a permis
de rallonger la liste des communes mais
dans mon département des haute pyrénée
cela ne représente que 27 communes sur
469 et certaines qui sont légitimement
concernés par la pénurie de logement ne
peuvent donc prétendre au financement de
la Banque des territoires ma question
est simple est-il envisagé d'étendre le
financement de ce dispositif au-delà des
zones tendues merci Madame la
Ministre merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice Artigalas vous
évoquez le fait que l'acquisition d'un
bien en BRS permet de faire des
économies à l'acquisition autour de 20 à
40 %
c'est tout à fait juste l'énorme
avantage c'est effectivement que c'est
un accès à la résidence principale
euh par contre vous dites il y a un
point négatif c'est le financement ce
point négatif on l'a tout le temps il
est pas lié au BRS ce point négatif lié
au financement effectivement que nous
avons dont nous avons décidé récemment
de le réduire aux zon tendu à quelques
exceptions que je vous ai cité
précédemment j'ai envie de vous dire
échangeons travaillons partageons tout
cela va faire l'objet d'amendements dans
le PLF et
donc que vous ayez peu de communes
considéré en zone tendue dans les hautes
Pyréné c'est exact qu'il y ait beaucoup
de communes qui puissent pas avoir accès
à ces financements je souscrit mais
aujourd'hui on a fait ce choix d'élargir
quand même la base mais quand même de se
concentrer alors on a monté les critères
tout ça a été largement décrit dans ma
déclaration générale et par les
sénateurs qui ont pris la parole donc
moi aujourd'hui je ne pense pas
pertinent alors qu'on vient de conduire
des évolutions significatives de
conduire encore des des évolutions
significatives cependant le dialogue est
toujours ouvert et mon collègue Patrice
vergrit ne manquera pas de prendre
contact avec vous pour échanger sur
cette
sollicitation merci Madame Artigalas il
vous reste 28
secondes son les critères des zones
tendu sont trop restrictifs face à la
crise actuelle du logement la tenstion
sur le logement est partout dans tous
les dans tous les communes mais pas que
les communes touristiques dans les
communes en périphérie aussi des zones
touristiques moi ce que je voulais quand
même vous dire c'est que on voit
vraiment l'extension du dispositif du BA
r solidaire permettrait un nombre plus
ant de ménage d'accéder à la propriété
on a un réel problème de logement dans
ce pays ça a été dit vous connaissez les
chiffres 2,42 million de personnes en
entendre de logement social c'est 1 1,61
pour une première il n'a jamais été
aussi levé il faut aussi lancer la
relance de production de logements
sociaux tout cela est extrêmement
important merci la parole est à notre
collègue Max Brisson pour le compoup
républicain pour 2
[Applaudissements]
minutes merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre en zone touristique
tendu l'accession à la propriété plus
particulement l'accession sociale par le
billet des bon Réal et solidaires est
une réponse que beaucoup de
municipalités souhaitent mené elles y V
en effet l'opportunité de rétablir de
réels parcours résidentiels et ainsi de
favoriser le logement des jeunes et leur
accession à la propriété or le
développement exponentiel des résidences
secondaires auquels nous assistons ces
dernières années rend très difficile la
maîtrise du foncier par les bailleurs
sociaux ou les collectivités locales
celle-ci assiste ainsi impuissante à une
importante rarifaction de leur foncier
rarifaction qui se répercute directement
sur l'accès à la propriété des classes
moyennes et des jeunes ménages la cause
principale de cette flambée du nombre de
résidents secondaires est connu c'est la
rentabilité en effet si le coût d'achat
peut paraître important celui-ci est
très rapidement amorti par le recours
aux locations saisonnière grâce à
l'entremise des plateformes numériques
et bien plus rapidement qu'and il a
recours à la location à l'année qui
s'effondre de même que la construction
de réels parcours résidentiels dans
lesquels l'accession sociale à la
propriété est un élément majeur dans ces
conditions paraît-il encore judicieux au
gouvernement de maintenir les
abattements fiscaux pour pouvant aller
jusqu'à 71 % pour laallocation de
meublés touristiqu ne faudrait-il pas au
contraire les supprimer notamment pour
les multi propriétaires ne faudrait-il
pas aussi assujettir à la TVA le produit
de ces locations saisonnières à partir
d'un certain seuil ne fautrait-il pas
enfin permettre aux communes de
bénéficier au-delà de la majoration
autorisée en son tendue de la
décorrélation de la thrrs par rapport à
la taxe
foncière merci Madame la
Ministre merci Monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur
Brisson en fait vous soullignez
l'absolue nécessité d'agir pour que nos
jeunes puissent accéder à la propriété
plus facilement vous avez raison on
souscrit on est en phase j'en profite
pour dire que pourquoi nous et et vous
m'invitez à à le souligner à ce
moment-là de de ma réponse mais pour
répondre à la sénatrice arti galas
pourquoi on cantonne l'accès du PTZ aux
zones tendu tout simplement parce que le
foncier il est entre deux à trois fois
plus élevé donc on veut rendre cette
accession plus abordable là où elle ne
l'est pas là où elle est effectivement
le P le PTZ n'est pas là ensuite vous
nous appelez vous appelez de vos vœux
que l'on revoit cette fiscalité vous
avez tout à fait raison et d'ailleurs le
travail est en cours il est en cours
depuis maintenant plusieurs mois il
était en cours au 18 juillet dans la
Réunion et groupe de travail auquel j'ai
fait allusion euh et je je souhaite
simplement vous dire que le travail est
conduit à la fois par notre Paul donc
Patrice vergrit moi-même Christophe
Béchu et en même temps Bercy pour
essayer de voir et avec vous comment
dans les amendements du PLF nous allons
revoir cette fiscalité parce que cette
fiscalité que vous considérez comme
haute à 71 % pour les meublés et non
meublés classés la question se pose
est-ce que on veut
encourager nos propriétaires
effectivement être exemplair sur le plan
de la prise en compte de euh
l'environnement et sur le plan de la
rénovation thermique donc oui pour
répondre favorablement à votre demande
de travailler cette fiscalité sur les
trois catégories meublé non meublé
classé meublé classé et puis ensuite
logement nu à votre disposition pour y
travailler merci monsieur le sénateur
merci Monsieur Brisson il vous reste 28
secondes madame le ministre vous dites
que vous êtes en phase et que nous avons
raison c le Sénat a voté l'année
dernière trois amendements qui
répondaient aux trois questions que je
vous avais posé et le ministre des
comptes publiques à l'époque avait dit
tout l'intérêt une fois de plus de ces
amendements sauf que lorsque le texte du
PLF est revenu à l'Assemblée nationale
avec le 493 vous avez fait sauter ces
trois amendements donc vos paroles ne
sont pas conformes à vos
actes merci la parole est à notre
collègue Guilain Cambier pour le groupe
Union centriste pour 2
minutes monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues politique
du logement sans traiter la question
foncière sans foncier n'est tout
simplement pas possible de réaliser des
nouvelles constructions et donc
d'accéder à la propriété en France le
foncier est devenu une denrée rare et
prisée sa raréfaction doit nous inciter
à penser autrement notre politique
d'accession à la propriété au logement
quelles sont nos options mes chers
collègues premièrement investir
massivement dans la rénovation
énergétique en 2022 ce sont ainsi plus
de 660000 dossiers qui ont été transmis
à l'Agence nationale de l'habitat mais
nous ne sommes pas à la hauteur du défi
pour l'instant en effet seul 10 %
d'entre eux se trouvent être des
rénovations globales les ambitions
annoncées par le Président de la
République lors du conseil de
planification écologique sont
encourageantes certes mais nous
attendons des actes deuxièmement bâtir
autrement là encore nous ne répondrons
pas présent nous sommes en plein milieu
d'une crise du logement neuf ça a été
rappelé tout à l'heure d'une ampleur
inédite et alarmante puisque le nombre
de logements neuf mis en vente à ainsi
chuté de près de 30 % entre 2022 et 2023
enfin nous devons mobiliser tous les
leviers disponibles pour lutter contre
l'explosion actuelle du prix du foncier
les prix les Français pardon les plus
modestes doivent pouvoir accéder à la
propriété comme les plus fortunés c'est
un enjeu majeur de justice sociale pour
notre pays pardà les mesures ponctuelles
et fragmentées madame la ministre
comment allez-vous rendre de nouveau le
foncier accessible à tous allons-nous
enfin bâtir une politique d'accession à
la propriété digne de notre pays et de
nos concitoyens je vous remercie merci
madame la
ministre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur Cambier
euh vous appelez d'abord de vos vœux que
nous investissions massivement sur la
rénovation des logements c'est pas moins
de 5 milliards d'euros que nous mettons
sur le sujet de la rénovation du parc
existant et vous nous vous appelez de de
vos vœux que notre politique soit plus
lisible plus claire plus mais je
n'entends rien malheureusement mais
peut-être n'ai-je pas bien compris
pourtant je vous ai bien écouté euh que
vous appeliez de vos vœux qui ne soi pas
dans nos outils
existant on les a largement listés le
BRS le PTZ ils sont lisibles ils sont
clairs on va les encourager on va les
pousser la banque des territoires dans
les offices fonciers solidaires les EPF
qui vont aider les collectivités à
maîtriser le foncier à éviter cette
inflation sur les prix du mètre carré du
foncier donc les outils sont là il me
semble clair lisiblebl il faut y mettre
de l'argent pour encourager à la fois le
neuf et la rénovation parce que les deux
marchent ensemble on peut pas
mettre et encourager la rénovation
uniquement comme vous l'avez dit il faut
qu'on mette de l'argent sur la
rénovation faut qu'on encourage aussi le
neuf faut qu'on encourage le logement
libre il faut qu'on encourage le
logement social donc je pense que les
débats que nous avons ici montrent que
le diagnostic est posé les solutions
sont là il faut les ajuster sont pas
parfaites mais face aux crises que l'on
rencontre oui on peut imaginer inventer
et quand vous dites il faut faire
autrement moi je suis l'exemple de
quelqu'un qui pousse à toujours faire
autrement et à inventer des nouveaux
dispositifs peut-être il y en a-t-il je
les ai pas compris je vous invite à à à
nous les dire de façon extrêmement
concise pour que je puisse les noter je
vous remercie merci Monsieur Combier
pour 33 secondes pour la réplique merci
madame la ministre de votre réponses en
fait ce qu'on constate c'est que souvent
les réponses sont techniques partiell
fragmenté et on a besoin du une
politique de d'ensemblier global une
vision à long terme une véritable
politique c'était le mot qui était
refusé tout à l'heure pour que on puisse
être clair non seulement auprès des
collectivités mais auprès des Français
or ce qu'on constate c'est qu'on a à
chaque fois quelques quelques éléments
techniques quelques réponses ponctuelles
mais pas de vision
globale merci madame la ministre vous
voulez
répondre monsieur le sénateur Cambier
merci de votre précision effectivement
je n'avais pas repris votre terme votre
sémantique vous considérez notre
politique comme fragmentée et pas
suffisamment politique en fait euh
s'il fallait euh pousser
euh un ou deux de nos outils dont on
parle largement depuis 1 heure en
détriment d'un autre nous serions me
semble-t-il dogmatique nous porterions
une politique ciblée sur le logement
social ciblée sur le logement libre non
notre politique elle est de conduire des
politiques en faveur du logement neuf de
la rénovation énergétique de servir nos
primau accédentss sociaux et de servir
un un une acquisition et une accession à
la propriété libre donc oui elle vous
paraît fragmentée parce qu'on a des
outils en fonction des politiques qui
sont conduites par les acteurs du
logement qui sont nos collectivités
locales donc elle n'est pas fragmentée
pour nous elle n'est pas dogmatique elle
n'est pas d'un seul bloc au service
d'une seule cause elle sert un peu tous
les euh toutes les formes de logement
pour servir le parcours du logement
merci Monsieur Cambier est-ce que vous
voulez utiliser votre réplique une
minute merci je crois que en fait il
faut savoir lire les chiffres et et les
regarder en face on a une véritable
crise du logement auquel sur lequel nous
nous pouvons tous nous mettre nous
mettre d'accord on peut pas dire qu'à
chaque fois la réponse est adaptée sinon
cette crise aurait disparu or on voit
qu'elle s'accroit euh d'année en année
euh et que cette année elle prend une
une accointance particulière donc il
nous c'est bien donc que les que les
réponses ne sont reste trop ponctuels
pour pouvoir justement débloquer
débloquer la situation on a besoin tout
à l'heure on vous interpollé sur
l'ambition de d'une France de
propriétaire c'était ma collègue gaker
qui qui vous posait la question on a
besoin de savoir où vous mettez le
curseur comment vous voulez vous y
prendre et avec quelle vision à long
terme vous voulez
poser merci la parole est à notre
collègue Denis BOAD pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
pour 2
minutes merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre j'ai connu une époque
où la dotion de parcours résidentiel
aait un sens et offrit une perspective à
la jeunesse du pays jeunes travailleurs
on prenit notre indépendance en
intégrant le parc locatif qui soit
social ou privé par la suite fonction de
l'évolution de notre situation familiale
ou professionnelle on pouvait déménager
dans un logement plus grand et dans
certains cas on envisageit d'accéder à
la propriété aujourd'hui cette simple
idée de parcours résidentiel est
beaucoup moins évidente de trop
nombreuses entrées de le parc social
sont définitives on y entre madame la
ministre et on y reste
de la même manière je connais certaines
communes de mon département où les
jeunes qui y grandissent et qui
aimeraient d'y vivre et y travailler ne
peuvent même pas envisager d'accéder à
la propriété dans leur propre commune du
fait des prix trop élevés en 40 ans le
taux des propriétaires parmi les jeunes
ménag parmi les jeunes ménages modestes
a été divisé par deux à terme cela
pourrait la poser la question sur la
mémoire l'identité de nos villages mais
aussi dans les inquiétudes vis-à-vis des
effectifs scolaires de certains
territoires face à ce phénomène nous
devons apporter des réponses adaptées
bien entendu cela cela a été dit il faut
maintenir et développer des outils
d'accession sociale à la propriété le
prêt à 30 qui a bien calibré a démontré
son efficacité le bail réel et solidaire
dont a parlé ma collègue Vian Artigalas
la vente de logements sociaux qui peut
également permettre aux bailleurs
sociaux de financer les opérations
nouvelles la TVA réduite sous certaines
conditions le prêt social location
accession tous ces dispositifs ont leur
utilité mais nous devons aussi regarder
les chiffres en 20 ans les prix de
l'immobilier ont été multipliés par prix
de 2 et demi de 2 et demi alors que les
coûts de la construction n augmenté que
de 50 %. nous avons donc un sujet de
spéculation foncière qui présente un
frein à l'accession sociale à la
propriété ainsi madame la ministre
quelle disposition structurante
comptez-vous mettre en œuvre pour pour
contter cette spéculation foncière et
ainsi favoriser l'accession à la
propriété et le parcours résidentiel de
ces jeunes ménages merci merci merci
Madame la
Ministre merci monsieur le Président euh
monsieur le sénateur je je vais pas
répéter tout ce qui a été dit il y a
beaucoup de choses qui ont déjà été
dites je vais en profiter pour essayer
de de de
synthétiser un petit peu notre position
pour la rendre j'ai envie de dire
peut-être plus
lisible
on est en face sur le fait que il nous
faut lutter contre la spéculation là où
elle se trouve il nous semble que les
outils qu'on a mis en place vont nous
aider à lutter contre cette spéculation
y compris dans nos villages et j'y suis
extrêmement attentive et si d'autres
outils sont àattir on est prêt à les
travailler avec vous mais je voudrais
quand même dire que 70000 crédits sont
encore accordés chaque mois donc 30 %
pour des primos accédents 30 30 % pour
des résidences principales par des
accédents qui dé ménag et 20 % pour des
investisseurs locatifs le PTZ je le
résume sera maintenu dans les zones
tendues pour les logements neufs et
élargi à de nouveaux ménages il sera
maintenu dans les zones détendues pour
les logements anciens tous ceux sur quoi
je lutte contre quoi je lutte avec
France ruralité c'est-à-dire les
logements vacants dans nos villages le
PTZ sera bien utilisable pour rénover
les les cœurs de village et les maisons
anciennes à rénover en parallèle nous
souhaitons acc améérer la rénovation
énergétique des logements en
accompagnant mieux les propriétaires
notre ambition est de continuer à tenir
la trajectoire de rénovation en offrant
une solution pour chaque propriétaire
notre PLF 2024 prévoit ainsi un budget
renforcé pour ma prime renve mais aussi
la possibilité pour les opérateurs de
logement intermédiaire d'acquérir des
logements anciens pour les rénover et
les mettre en location à des loyers
abordables pour les classes moyenne et
les outils sont donc en plus de ce que
je vous avais cité précédemment
multiples pour garantir à la la fois le
respect de l'urgence écologique à
laquelle je sais que vous êtes attaché
et la prise en compte de l'urgence
sociale dans un contexte de crise du
logement je vous remercie merci la
parole est à notre collègue Laurent
Duplon pour le groupe les républicains
pour 2
[Applaudissements]
minutes madame la ministre depuis
quelques années vous appartenez à un
gouvernement qui n'a eu de cess à tué
l'accession à la priété et en
particulier c'est l'accession à la
propriété en campagne j'en veux cinq
bonnes raisons la première c'est que
dans toutes les communes de campagne qui
ont eu la possibilité de développer le
gaz naturel ils ont détruit leur route
leur trottoir pour faire la possibilité
d'accéder à la propriété plus facilement
et d'avoir la possibilité de se chauffer
plus facilement avec un coût de
chaudière moins moins moins élevé vous
avez depuis 2022 dans toutes les
constructions neuves interdit les
chaudières à gaz ce qui fait que toutes
les communes qui ont investi se sentent
totalement dépourvu de cette possibilité
la deuxième c'est que vous n'avez eu de
cess au niveau écologique d'augmenter
les normes sur tous les lotissements en
campagne qu'ils sont fait j'en ai pour
preuve la la commune de saint-pulien 35
lots l'obligation sur 35 lots de laisser
un lot pour les grenouilles trème
élément c'est que votre gouvernement par
le quoi qu'il en coûte a obligé et
entraîner l'inflation des matériaux qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui l'accession à la
propriété par la construction devient de
plus en plus difficile enfin le 4e la 4è
raison c'est l'augmentation des taux
vous nous expliquez ou du moins ministre
de l'Économie encore actuellement
ministre nous expliquit que quand on
emprunte à taux négatif on gagne de
l'argent et ben c'est fini à 5 % non
seulement on n gagne pas mais les jeunes
qui n'ont pas les moyens ne construisent
plus et pour finir vous allez encore en
rajouter une couche puisque que dans le
zéro artificialisation nette à partir de
2031 il faudra déconstruire pour
construire seulement madame la ministre
comment vous expliquez que pour
déconstruire et bien il y aura la
possibilité aussi pour ceux qui
déconstruiront d'exporter ce droit à
d'autres endroits en France ce qui veut
dire qu'on va dépouiller le milieu rural
de ces droits à construire pour les
exporter ailleurs alors ma question
monsieur le Président est simple ne
croyez-vous pas madame la ministre que
cette politique bobo écolo plutôt
parisienne est va à l'encontre totale du
développement de nos campagnes et
qu'après avoir investi des milliards
d'euros à l'aménagement du territoire
vous êtes pas en train de faire le
travail inverse c'est-à-dire le
déménagement du territoire merci Madame
la
[Applaudissements]
Ministre bon monsieur le Président je
vous remercie monsieur le sénateur du
plomb voilà une prise de parole que moi
je peux qualifier de a charge contre la
politique du gouvernement mais on est là
pour débattre euh cette prise de parole
est à charge ce qui fait que j'ai du mal
à me raccrocher euh à des choses
constructives quand vous me dites qu'il
y a un lot qui est réservé pour les
grenouilles sur 35 lots oui on assume
que l'on porte une politique où la
planification écologique est en
transverse la planification écologique
et la transition écologique sont au cœur
de toutes nos politiques publiques je
veux vous rappeler que ce que vous
soullignez comme effectivement la hausse
des coûts et la crise du logement et la
hausse des taux d'intérêt euh le coût de
construction depuis 20 ans n'a augmenté
que de 50 % donc on est là dans quelque
chose qui est
relativement modéré et ensu si vous
voulez nous accuser d'une politique bobo
bon peut-être écolo vous pouvez on est à
charge moi je suis fière d'appartenir à
un gouvernement qui a mis la transition
écologique au cœur et effectivement sans
dogmatisme donc très étonné de voir un
lot réservé au grenouill je vous
remercie merci la parole est à notre
collègue remémy Cardon pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
pour 2 minutes merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre Dominique
fort je souhaite attirer votre attention
sur la question de l'accession à la
propriété pour les jeunes ménages primo
acccédent en particulier ceux qui
résident en dehors des zones tendues
actuellement le pré àau zéro joue un
rôle significatif dans l'accession à la
propriété pour les les primau accédents
et bien que le ministre le maire ait
annoncé l'extension du pré at Z0 à 6
millions de de personnes supplémentaires
je crains que celui-ci ne soit pas en
mesure d'apporter le soutien nécessaire
au primo accéd notamment dans les
territoires ruraux il s'agit là d'un
très mauvais signal donné en particulier
au primo acccédent des territoires
ruraux vous le savez en raison de la
flambée des prix et en particulier des
taux d'emprunt et des difficultés
immobilières que nous traversons de
nombreux jeunes de ménag ont de plus en
plus de difficultés à accéder à la
propriété et ils sont exclus déjà
d'office des zones tendues mais pour des
raisons
financière forc forcer ces derniers à se
positionner là où la demande excède
l'offre de logement disponible ne me
semble pas être une position tenable
vous semblez abandonner les zones
henstion à savoir nos territoires ruraux
en grande partie c'est dommage pour une
ministre chargée des ruralités alors que
la situation est particulièrement
préoccupante nos villages madame la
ministre constituent bien souvent le
dernier endroit où les jeunes ont des
capacités financières de s'installer et
vous les excusez du champ PTZ cela
favorise l'éviction des jeunes de
village et par effet de suite un non non
renouvellement de de la population et
par effet domino parfois la fermeture de
classe puisque nous avons des
difficultés à accueillir des jeunes
familles alors ma question elle est très
simple madame la ministre quelle mesure
le gouvernement envisage-t-il de mettre
en place pour soutenir les jeunes
ménages souhaitant accéder à la
propriété dans les zones hors tension et
notamment dans les territoires ruraux
merci merci madame la
ministre monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le sénateur
Cardon beaucoup de choses ont été dites
oui je pense que effectivement les 6
millions de personnes
supplémentaires vont pouvoir bénéficier
du PTZ mais je suis étonné par votre
question parce que je pensais y avoir
répondu donc je vous redis que le PTZ
est
ouvert pour les accédentss à la
propriété sur des logements en
ils sont on est en zone non tendue et on
peut acquérir un logement ancien dans
nos villages pour le rénover très bien
est-ce que vous savez le nombre de
logements vacants dans nos villages que
dans nos villages en France 800000
800000 logements vacants donc oui
j'assume que le gouvernement veuille
encourager dans des zones non tendues
donc où l'acquisition du foncier n'est
pas aussi élevé qu'ailleurs privilégie
la rénovation d'ancien pour encourager
la l'acquisition et la rénovation de
maisons anciennes parce que voilà si on
prend des villages avec un nombre
d'habitants moyens de 1200 1250
habitants c'est en moyenne entre 100 et
200 logements vacants donc oui avant
d'aller construire des lotissements oui
on assume notre politique de sobriété
foncière à laquelle je suis sûr que vous
souscrivez et oui on met le paquet par
contre pour permettre à ces jeunes
d'accéder à des logements anciens pour
qu'ils les rénovent donc tout ça me
semble cohérent on peut évidemment
regretter que le logement neuf en
ruralité ne soit pas accompagné par du
PTZ mais je pense en avoir expliqué les
raisons je vous
remercie merci Monsieur Cardon il vous
reste 9 secondes pour la réplique juste
pour compléter mon mon propos vous
parlerz effectivement de 154 nouvelles
communes qui sont concernées dans les
propos de Monsieur le Maire sachez que
moi dans la Somme c'est 772 communes en
fait donc si vous voulez et Monsieur le
Maire parlait au niveau de toute la
France de la nation moi je parle juste
de de mon département si vous le compte
est on est très très loin du compte pour
le coup et est du coup ciblé uniquement
les logements vacants pour la ruralité
c'est quand même très rabaissant madame
la
ministre merci la parole est à notre
collègue Martine Berté pour le groupe
les républicains pour 2
minutes merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre déficit naturel de
foncier pression touristique forte
obligation législative et réglementaire
spécifique la question de la pénurie de
logement se pose avec une acuité
particulière pour les territoires de
montagne face à ce cocktail explosif
débouchant sur une élévation
exponentielle des prix de l'immobilier
l'amélioration des conditions
d'implantation de l'habitat permanent
est devenu une priorité pour les
communes support de station en effet
leur maire observateur privilégiés de ce
phénomène n'ont toujours pas à leur
disposition la boîte à outils adéquate
pour prendre les mesures adaptées et
nécessaires à à leur territoire qui sont
tous différents à titre d'exemple malgré
le dernier arrêté trop de stations de
montagne subissent encore un zonage non
pertinent au regard de leur situation et
sont donc exclus des dispositifs qui
pourraient en concourir au maintien de
leur population PTZ prè socicial
location accession bail réel solidaire
c'est dans ce contexte que j'ai pris
connaissance avec grand intérêt de
l'interview de votre collègue ministre
du Logement samedi dernier dans le monde
où il est explicite un peu plus
clairement la volonté présidentielle de
décentralisation de la politique du
logement sachant que nos maires sont en
attente de cette liberté d'action aussi
dans la droite ligne de cette nouvelle
philosophie et en lien avec une mesure
annoncée en juillet dernier je
souhaitais vous interroger sur la
nécessité d'adapter les outils
d'urbanisme pour permettre aux communes
support de station via leur plu de
favoriser le développement d'habitats
permanents et l'acction à la propriété
aussi madame la ministre seriez-vous
favorable à la création au sein des PLU
d'une sous-catégorie habitat permanent
pour les commune touristique ou quels
autres outils le gouvernement pense-t-il
mettre en œuvre en ce sens je vous
remercie merci Madame la
Ministre merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice
Berté je je vous confirme les travaux
que nous conduisons depuis déjà quelques
mois sur la décentralis du logement
donc toute proposition à la matière tous
travaux sont les bienvenus au niveau de
notre ministre Christophe Béchu de
Patrice vergriet de
moi-même on avance assez vite d'ailleurs
depuis maintenant un mois et on y voit
assez clair mais l'idée c'est un peu de
pouvoir échanger avec vous ensuite vous
appelez de vos vœux une adaptation de la
règle des règles d'urbanisme dans les
stations de montagne dans dans les
stations en zone tendue la réponse est
oui la réponse est oui elle est au cœur
de nos préoccupations dans le cadre du
groupe de travail dont je vous parlais
toujours 18 juillet nous avons ouvert
une réflexion
sur l'absolue nécessité d'adapter nos
règlements d'urbanisme à ces territoires
donc sur la fiscalité je vous confirme
ce que j'ai déjà dit c'estd que on est
en train d'y travailler pour
effectivement permettre d'encourager
toujours l'investissement dans ces zones
tendu mais mettre une fiscalité un peu
plus en adéquation avec les politiques
publiques que je crois on partage merci
merci Madame Bert il vous reste 11
secondes alors madame la ministre merci
groupe de travail c'est très bien
derrière il faut que ce soit suivi
d'application concrète car pour
l'instant tout va dans le sens inverse
de ce que nous voulons plus de
déplacement pour nos jeunes qui ne
peuvent pas rester habités sur
place merci la parole est à notre
collègue Sylvi Noël pour le groupe les
républicains pour 2
minutes
merci
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre face au défis qui se présente à
nous en matière de logement l'immense
majorité des mer'inestissent pour se
conformer aux différents objectifs
imposés en matière de logements sociaux
et d'accession sociale à la propriété en
dépit des difficultés budgétair
croissante des recours juridiques
nombreux et des injonctions parfois
contradictoires de l'État alors que la
crise du logement que nous vivons
devrait fédérer les énergies et
récompenser les efforts réalisés forcz
de constater que l'attitude de l'État
est parfois très décourageante voire
stigmatisante pour les élus en dépit de
leurs efforts ainsi en mars dernier un
décret est venu relever le seuil de
tension sur la demande de logement
social mesuré à l'échelle des
territoires concernés par la loi etu
amenant certaines communes à passer de
20 à 25 % de production de logements
sociaux entraînant mathématiquement et
immédiatement un doublement de la
pénalité su payable sans délais pour les
maires de ces communes cette pénalité
constitue une sanction insupportable à
plusieurs titres financièrement d'abord
car elle intervient de manière
rétroactive dans un contexte
particulièrement délicat pour les
collectivités locales compte tenu de
l'explosion de leur charge de
fonctionnement et de la chute d'une
partie de leur recette juridiquement
ensuite car cette pénalité vient comme
un coup près sanctionné sans aucun délai
et sans préavis la non atteinte d'un
objectif qui ne s'imposait pas
jusqu'alors aux communes ce qui est
particulièrement discutable humainement
enfin en sanctionnant des élus qui pour
l'immense majorité sont particulièrement
actifs pour tenter de résorber le retard
de production de logements sociaux et ne
voient pas leurs efforts récompensés
bien au contraire qui plus est dans des
départements confrontés à la rareté et à
la chireté du foncier aussi dans un
contexte où la France pourrait manquer
de 850000 logements en 2030 l'état
entend-il enfin instaurer une véritable
politique partenariale et incitative à
destination des élusrant activement en
faveur du logement social en location ou
en accession sociale à la propriété je
vous remercie madame la
ministre monsieur le
président madame la sénatrice Noël donc
pour répondre très vite à votre question
oui nous entendons conduire une
politique
partenariale avec les collectivités
locales simplement vous dire que la loi
s elle a quand même permis de dynamiser
la production de logements sociaux dont
plus de la moitié sont situés dans des
communes déficit
elle permet aussi de renforcer
l'investissement des communes dans le
logement social via les prélèvements
imposés le taux a été ramené vous l'avez
vu ces dernières années à 20 % le de 25
aujourd'hui on revient à cet objectif de
25 parce qu'il y a de la tension et que
on a besoin de logements sociaux on est
aussi attaché à une application de la
loi en lien étroit avec les territoires
d'où ce terme de partenariat que vous
avez évoqué et auquel je souscris c'est
le sens des contrats de mixité sociale
créés par la loi 3DS en février 2020 22
qui permettent d'adapter les objectifs
de production et surtout de recenser
tous les leviers de production de
logement les logements en accession
sociales sont comptabilisés dans la loi
SRU aujourd'hui euh pardon grâce à
vous en particulier les BRS sont pris en
compte dans le calcul du déficit une
commune peut donc à la fois respecter
ses obligations SRU et produire un
nombre important de logement en
accession sociale l'accession sociale va
être soutenue dans tous les territoires
tendus et détendu je l'ai
expliqué de façon différente le PTZ sera
maintenu pour cette accession pour le
BRS le PSLA la vente HLM et l'accession
sociale en zone en rue les plafonds de
ressources des ménages éligibles on être
étendus dans les prochaines semaines par
voie réglementa donc de nombreuses
familles seront rendues éligibles je
vous
remercie merci la parole est à notre
collègue MarieClaire carerg pour le
groupe les républicains pour 2
minutes monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Madame
la ministre mes chers collègues en 10
ans Paris a perdu 120000 habitants et le
logement figure au premier rang des
motifs de cette saignée l'accession à la
propriété constitue un horizon
inatteignable pour l'immense majorité
les jeunes nés à Paris savent qu'ils ne
pourront pas vivre et s'installer chez
eux dans leur ville quel que soit leur
parcours professionnel qu'une ville
rejette ses propres enfants et cruel
c'est surtout de très mauvais augur pour
l'avenir une ville doit savoir attirer
et conserver sa jeunesse ses talents
toutes celles et tous ceux qui vont
étudier travailler créer c'est également
le cas pour les enseignants soignants
artisans policiers tous se retrouvent
relégués hors de Paris avec un accès
limité au marché locatif et zéro
perspective de devenir
propriétaire pour beaucoup être
locataire c'est un choix bien sûr mais
les inégalités de patrimoine et donc de
revenu au moment de la retraite entre
propriétaire et locataire sont terribles
face à cela le projet au plutôt le choix
de société de Madame hiidalgo c'est
d'avoir 40 % de logements sociaux à
Paris en préemptant à touvard de telle
sorte que le marché est de plus en plus
étroit entre la spéculation foncière et
les achats de riches non résidents
étrangers cela diminue d'autant
l'étendue du marché locatif car on le
sait sans accession à la à la propriété
il n'y a pas non plus assez de logement
alloué la mairie de Paris invoque alors
sans doute pour amuser la galerie Le
Bail réel solidaire cette technique qui
a du sens dans les communes qui dis POS
de foncier est de la poudre aux yeux à
Paris et une injustice supplémentaire à
Paris où il y a à peu près autant de
chance de se voir attribuer un logement
en BRS que de gagner au loto combien
comment comptez-vous madame la ministre
favoriser une réelle accession à la
propriété à Paris et dans les autres
grandes villes de France je vous
remercie merci madame la
ministre monsieur le Président Madame la
S sénatrice carerg je présente mes
excuses madame la sénatrice tout à
l'heure donc oui et je rajouterai même à
la liste de ceux qui sont renvoyés hors
de Paris les pompiers donc les gendarmes
les policiers vous avez cité un certain
nombre de nos fonctionnaires auquels on
est très attaché qui effectivement ont
du mal à se loger compte tenu de du prix
au mètre carré dans Paris ensuite vous
évoqué la politique en matière de de
logement de la M de Paris je suis pas
habilitée à porter un un jugement en
tout cas on est dans le champ de la
politique locale de l'habitat donc le
constat que vous faites je le partage je
vois qu'elle a embarqué le BRS récemment
tant mieux mais en tout cas comment
favoriser comment pas suffisamment
peut-être je sais pas mais en tout cas
comment accompagner comment favoriser
rien de plus que ce que je vous ai dit
sur les hommes tendus parce que
évidemment on voit à Paris c'est
exacerbé ce qu'on voit à Lyon ce qu'on
voit à Bordeaux ce qu'on voit à Lille ce
qu'on voit à Marseille donc moi je pense
que ce que l'on a dit jusqu'à maintenant
sont sont des outils qui sont destinés à
la mise en œuvre d'une politique de
l'habitaat qui permet l'accession à nos
jeunes à la propriété l'accession
sociale mais l'accession libre aussi
donc je n'ai pas de réponse spécifique
pour Paris à vous faire à ce jour je
vous remercie merci Madame carerg il
vous reste 16 secondes pour une réplique
oui ce n'est pas vous faire au fonce
madame la ministre je crois c'est pas
votre portefeuille ministère mais que de
constater que les multiples mesures que
vous avez égriné sont me paraissent pas
à la hauteur de l'enjeu de d'une crise
qui frappe tout le monde on a vu à
travers toutes nos questions des des
zones de montagne à Paris et je pense
qu'il faudrait des actions
spécifiques il faudrait une une
véritable politique une politique ses
objectifs une stratégie et des moyens et
ça pardonnez-moi on entend la boîte à
outil qui rappelle celle d'un président
de la République Monsieur Hollande face
au chômage on entend la boîte à outil
mais on voit pas la politique je suis
désolé merci beaucoup merci la parole à
Madame la Ministre pour une réplique
juste un mot pour souligner simplement
un point don on a largement débattu mais
qui est le fait qu'on a augmenté le
plafond de ressources qui quand même
permet à un plus grand nombre d'accéder
assez près donc en espérant que ça soit
suffisant mais toute proposition est
tout à fait bonne à prendre
euh je vous ai entendu madame car RG
est-ce que vous voulez répliquer merci
la parole est à notre collègue
Jean-Claude danglar pour le groupe les
républicains pour 2
minutes merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre depuis une vingtaine
d'années cela a été rappelé largement
cet après-midi l'accession à la
propriété est problématique car il
existe un décalage croissant entre le
souhait des Français d'être propriétaire
et la difficulté à le devenir ainsi en
2023 les propriétaires représentent
seulement 58 % des ménages quand
l'accession à la propriété est un ObjC
principal pour les Français par exemple
parmi les 18 300 ans 80 % des nonom
propriéires souhaitent le devenir selon
un sondage de l'ifob de 2022 cette
situation est un enjeu de société tant
l'accession à la proprieté et facteur de
promotion et d'intégration sociale dans
ce débat je voudrais surtout attirer
votre attention comme l'ont fait mes
collègues madame la ministre sur l'enjeu
de l'accession à la proprieté dans les
territoires ruraux suite au choix du
gouvernement relatif à la politique du
Zéro artificial isationtion nette l'une
des questions majeures qui est posée par
le zan est en effet celle de l'accession
à la propreté dans les territoires
ruraux le zan est une politique qui
s'inscrit dans une logique plutôt
comptable commode pour l'État mais moins
pour les programmes locaux d'urbanisme
derrière les impératifs de renaturation
de sobriété foncière et de
revitalisation du bâti de fortes
contraintes vont s'imposer aux communes
rurales or vous le savez de nombreux
ménages ne peuvent aujourd'hui accéder à
la propriéé que par la habitat
individuel dans des territoires où le
foncier est peu cher c'est-à-dire dans
des territoires dit périphériques
urbains comme ruraux l'objectifant de
risque de remettre en cause cette
possibilité y compris même avec ceux que
nous avons gagné ici la garantie rurale
de 1 hactare pour chaque commune d'ici à
2031 en ce sens plusieurs travaux du
Sénat ont montré que le zan touchera en
priorité les classes moyennes modestes
habitant ou souhaitant habiter en zon
rurale et périurbaine et qui verront
leur projets d' accession à la propreté
rendu de plus en plus difficile face à
ce risque majeur pour le développement
de ces territoires déjà marqué par des
inégalités vis-à-vis des communes les
plus denses quelles sont donc les
solutions prévues par le gouvernement
pour soutenir l'accès à la propriété en
milieu rural merci Madame la
Ministre merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Sénateur
Anglars vous savez de quoi vous parlez
en évoquant les possibles
difficulté que avec notre objectif de
zéro artificialisation nette à 2050 et
50 % d'artificialisation en moins à
horizon de 2030 on puisse éventuellement
euh avoir des difficultés pour accéder à
la propriété donc je crois que beaucoup
de choses ont été dites la politique du
gouvernement elle est claire elle est de
mettre le paquet sur la rénovation
énergétique et la rénovation tout court
de tous nos 800000 logements vacants on
va accompagner par France ruralité tous
les maires qui le souhaitent dans en
ingénierie pour être capable de lutter
contre ces logements vacants et être
capable de rénover ces maisons de
village que nos jeunes aiment beaucoup
et les réhabiliter et les rendre
attractifes pour tous ceux qui voudront
s'y installer ensuite quand vous dites
et c'est et c'est et c'est votre opinion
et je la respecte que les classes
moyennes en ruralité pourraient subir de
par cet objectif de zéro
artificialisation net une une difficulté
à pouvoir s'installer euh moi je vous
réponds que on est à horizon 2030 on est
à horizon 2050 on porte une politique
publique dont on est fier de réduire
l'artificialisation des sols on on
seraattend dans 1 an dans 2 ans dans 3
ans quand cette garantie rurale sera
prise en main par nos élus locaux et que
ils seront limités alors on pourra
reravailler
ensemble pour faire évoluer les choses
mais là laissons à cette objectif le
temps de se mettre en place avec cette
garantie rurale que le Sénat a voulu sa
grande majorité et puis évaluons
ensemble oui ou non si nos jeunes
peuvent accéder à la propriété dans nos
dans nos beaux villages merci merci
madame la ministre pour conclure le
débat la parole est à notre collègue
Jean-Baptiste blanc pour le groupe les
républicains pour 5
minutes merci monsieur le Président
Madame et la ministre chers collègues ce
débat sur l'accession à la propriété
demandé par mon groupe les républicain a
donc permis des échanges substantiels
nous l'avons bien vu il a montré que les
chantiers sont son encore à venir et que
nombre de mécanismes juridiques mérite
d'être repensés c'est un véritable sujet
à tiroir que nous avons évoqué cet
après-midi permettraz d'aborder en
conclusion trois quatre séries de
chantiers difficultés qui me semble
devoir être soulevés pour conclure cet
après-midi tout d'abord celui de la
fiscalité locale premier chantier qui
doit être repensé afin de permettre un
équilibre entre d'un côté la nécessité
d'accroître les ressources des
collectivités et de l'autre l'impératif
d'accession à la propriété pour les les
Français à ce titre la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation sur les résidences
principales a des effets néfastes tant
pour les communes que sur les
propriétaire avec l'augmentation
inévitable de la taxe foncière sur les
propriétés bâtiques qui pèsent
lourdement sur ces mêmes propriétaires
madame et la ministre on a assisté tout
l'été un jeu extrêmement malsin entre
l'État et les collectivités locales sur
ce jeu euh précisément du relèvement du
de la taxe foncière sur le propriété
bâti il faut en sortir une piste c'est
celle c'est celle de de la fiscalité du
zan qui va bien falloir financer ce ce
modèle et réinventer une fiscalité
locale et une vraie à l'Ô de ces
nouveaux objectifs deuxème chantier euh
vous ne pourrez pas vous contenter des
annonces du CNR sur le logement dont les
conclusions on étaient exposées en juin
dernier euh qui ont en commun l'absence
d' ambition véritablement marquée qui
permettrait de ralentir cette crise
accélérée et historique du du logement
qu'en toile de fond il s'agit de ça cet
après-midi et euh vous ne pourrez pas
vous contenter de demander à Action
Logement de palier les insuffisances de
de l'État il va falloir faire autre
chose et faire preuve davantage
d'imagination troème chantier c'est
celui du modèle pavillonnaire c'est en
toile de fond c'est le zan mais en toile
de fond c'est aussi le modèle
pavillonnaire le malaise vient de
l'ancienne ministre avec des propos
malheureux en fin de discussion sur la
loi climat et résilience le malaise
vient aussi d'un décret sur
l'artificialisation qui a été annulé
c'est jour-ci par le Conseil d'État le
malaise vient d'un nouveau décret auquel
nous avons été associés l vrait pendant
la CMP sur sur le zan mais donc vous
savez très bien que le gouvernement
cherchant des stocks de fronciers pour
faire du pavillon sur le pavillon pour
faire de la ville
dense a pu nous amener à penser que vous
vouliez en finir avec ce modèle
pavillonnaire s'il avait pas eu le le
l'apport du Sénat dans cette CMP pour
sauver une forme de pavillon tu as bien
compris qu'on pouvait plus le faire
comme avant il y aurait pas eu une
avancée et alors forcé de constater que
cette affaire de PTZ est venue tout
remettre à zéro c'est le cas de le dire
c'està-dire que on a l'impression que
malgré tout vous voulez en finirvec avec
ce modèle alors que c'est pas vraiment
l'accord que nous avons eu dans cette
discussion puisque nous voulions
concilier véritablement environnement et
une forme de modèle pavillonnaire en
tout cas considérer que c'est du cas par
cas c'est qu'il y a aucun territoire en
France qui ressemble à l'autre parfois
le pavillonnaire est une réponse parfois
il ne l'est pas parfois il est possible
parfois il ne l'est pas d'où cette
frustration que nous avons d'un article
de notre proposition de loi qui a
disparu qui permettait de donner une
forme de liberté aux élus de dire ceux
qui veulent voir densifier ce qu'il
veulent voir renaturer ce qui nous amène
ce qui m'amène là à conclure par le
dernier chantier qui est celui des
outils on a parlé au Sénat des EPF qu'il
faut muscler parce qu'ils sont des des
bons outils mais il faut aussi évoquer
tous les autres outils parmi lesquels
SEM semop
EPF je vais évoquer mais SEM semop SPL
peut-être des ACS qu'il faut faire
évoluer des secteurs de renouvellement
pavillonnaire qu'il faut inventer voilà
c'est ça fait partie de ces chantiers
sans lesquels il y aura pas de déblocage
réel de ce de ce cette crise du du
logement et sans lesquels on pourra pas
accéder à la propriété notamment en ce
qui concerne les Primot accédant et en
milieu rural de très nombreux collègues
l'ont l'ont soulevé l'ont soulevé ça et
là donc en fait on est vraiment au
devant de très très nombreux chantiers
en marge de ce ce sujet hein qui qui est
un peu notre point de focalisation cet
après-midi mais que que si notre reprise
de travaux pouvait être ce symbole là
qu'on s'y met tous pour tout réinventer
euh ça pourrait être une bonne chose je
vous
remercie merci mes chers collègues je
vais suspendre la séance pour quelques
instants afin de de permettre à chacun
de de s'installer pour le prochain point
à l'ordre du jour je vous
remercie